EO will be the first Marvel series to
debut on both Disney plus and Hulu and
it'll also be the first MCU series to
receive a tvma rating which means that
it'll be more violent and mature than
other Marvel shows the approach is
reminiscent of that of earlier Marvel
series like Daredevil Jessica Jones and
Luke Cage which were more explicit and
also rated tvma the series will also be
under the Marvel Spotlight Banner which
is a new subcategory of Marvel that will
focus on Standalone stories that are not
directly connected to the main MCU
storyline the series will consist of
five episodes and it will be released in
its entirey on January 10th 2024